I remember I saw a therapist I went to
Tulane for like a year and a half in New
Orleans I remember I saw a therapist
there it was so weird it looked like
dude it was Katrina had just hit so the
it was like a flooded hospital where I
saw this therapist it looked like it
looked like Shutter Island it was the
weirdest [__] I've ever seen you know I
but my mom's like this is the therapist
you're gonna see so I was like all right
you know it's kind of like a you know I
acted out a lot uh so I remember I saw
this therapist and he was like roasty
that's the only way to like he was kind
of a dick he was really smart and a good
therapist but he would like Zing you
like I remember I was like yes I was
given my background I was like well
there's a few years it was just me and
my mom and he goes you and Mommy against
the world and I was like what the [__]
what's your problem
that is weird I was like I didn't know I
picked Rickles to uh go through my [__]